joining us now is Rabbi Angela buchdahl
she's a senior Rabbi at Central
synagogue right here in New York City
Rabbi bugtong we're very glad you're
here you know I've heard you say what he
just said at the end of the piece that
this is so much bigger than Kanye that
we really should take the spotlight off
of Kanye but he does have a big platform
so we have to say something don't you
think well it is much bigger than Kanye
but let's start with the fact that Kanye
is Big just to put a little perspective
on it
um he has 30 million over 30 million
Twitter followers which is more than
double the population of all the Jews of
the world there are fewer than 15
million Jews in the world I don't think
people realize I don't think people
understand what a small community we are
globally and um and yet so one man
having a platform that is twice as big
as if every Jewish person in the world
tried to reach someone it still is not
as big as his platform so I think that
we have to not underestimate what one
person's platform could be but it's so
much bigger than that because it's also
it's not just about one person it's also
not just about anti-Semitism against
Jews he's essentially activated an army
of people who hate and are serial haters
and you know you evidence of that is
just the clip we saw of the white
supremacists um these are people who
don't just hate Jews they actually hate
people of color minorities differences
looking for any reason exactly somebody
something so this is um when we tolerate
that kind of language it might start
with hatred or conspiracy theories of
Jews but it always extends to anyone who
is of difference I mean uh anti-Semitism
is often called the world's oldest
hatred at least in recorded history yeah
where does it come from
well there are many routes it's at least
you know as as long as there have been
Jews there has been hatred of Jews
unfortunately
um there has been you know the Christian
church had a whole doctrine that was
that was very explicitly anti-semitic
um and throughout all the generations
and ages there have been ways that this
has morphed and um evolved it's very
resilient this hatred it is very
resilient however um there are some like
foundational principles that have kind
of remained the same and just sort of
have different permutations uh issues of
you know kind of blood thirst of Jewish
greed of conspiracy theory uh that Jews
kind of control and run everything so
back in the day it was about Banks now
it's about the media so it it Morrison
changes but it is but some principles of
uh basically that the world's problems
can be uh blamed on the Jews that's
that's the bottom line a population of
just 15 million people right and I'm
glad you brought that up because one of
those tropes or narratives is the
control of Hollywood or Media or Banks
and money pulling strings behind the
scenes for those who might not
understand that that are sitting at home
saying well if you have power what's
what's the big deal about it why is that
such a bad thing for those who don't
understand that narrative first of all
it is um very it puts Jews in a terrible
situation and a catch-22 as my as my
friend yair Rosenblum said that um you
know if we do nothing we let this go
unchecked if we actually say something
and something happens like Adidas drops
him jobs yay then they say look see how
you told yourself look at how powerful
the Jews are they can they can drop and
make Adidas lose 250 million dollars so
it is a very
um horrible situation I will say though
that um I personally experience this
myself when there was a gunman who came
from England and held a rabbi and four
and three others hostage in a synagogue
in Colleyville Texas I received a phone
call from the terrorist saying you Jews
are influential and powerful and I need
you to get this prisoner out of federal
prison and I said I don't have that
power he said oh of course you do you
run a large synagogue in New York so
that just is to tell you that like one
man's uh craziness but it's not just one
man he has been fed this in a system of
anti-Semitic rhetoric
um if you want to think about why it's
dangerous to say Jews have power and
influence think about a man who holds
four people at gunpoint for 10 hours
because he believes Jews have influenced
people so it's a life and death issue
when people look at you Rabbi booked all
they think well that's not what I expect
a rabbi to look like that's right I
haven't I've heard that before so I I
would just say that I think one of the
problems of anti-Semitism today is
people really have no understanding of
who the Jewish Community is
um there is certainly in America
misunderstanding that Jews have always
just been white people
um clearly not and that's actually not
been who the Jewish Community has been
historically over you know Millennia and
um so I think that part of this is about
educating ourselves about who we are but
but part of this is also about um just
rhetoric that wants to put Jews into a
particular box did it bother you that
companies seem to take a a long they
took several weeks to decide that
they're going to disengage from him does
that send a message to you yeah I think
the people are kind of weighing their
bottom line and um and I think that it
was disappointing that it took so long
for for people but I really appreciate
that ultimately
um people did the right thing I'm not
going to go into whether or not I think
the motivations for why they did It
ultimately I think a bottom line if
you're if your best asset is your brand
and you allow your brand to be
associated with a bigoted hateful you
know um you know Army of people I think
that that is your bottom line but how do
you shine a light on this without giving
it a platform
you know that that's what I struggle
with I would say shine a light on
anti-Semitism shine a light on the
anti-Semitism and don't shine it on the
anti-semite because that actually gives
more oxygen so don't give Kanye
um more interviews he just uses it as a
platform to spew more hate and it gives
him it is the oxygen that feeds that
fire and and all his and his army of of
followers I think what you do is you
actually talk about the anti-semitic
rhetoric and you point it out and you
condemn it but but actually don't give
so much attention to the person who's
saying it that's for Solutions well
we're glad you conversation thank you
we're glad you're here to give it the
appropriate amount thank you I
appreciate you doing it Rabbi Angela
book doll thank you very much appreciate
it